yeah we have to be ready you we the
others
miss Mitaka
far away
not coming it's already here the others
where are they Arthur curry the Aquaman
Sonam again again biomechatronics body
part he's a cyborg you should probably
move Barry Allen
whoever you're looking for it's not me
do Batman
[Music]
they said the age of heroes who never
come again
[Applause]
what are your superpowers again a rich
you got to watch
[Music]
shall we
it's good to see you playing well with
others again just like a bat I dig it
may be temporary
you
oh my god everybody we got to freak out
about this so because this is so awesome
I'm doing a new round of the injustice
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video you dress like a bat I dig it
it's good to see you playing well with
others so the trailer itself covers a
bunch of different time periods we even
flash all the way back to the origin of
the DC Universe with the Amazon fighting
in this open field against this giant
apocalyptan army so what I'll do because
there's so much stuff in here so I'll
just do this as we go along through the
trailer shop I shot the opening dialogue
talks about having to bring the people
together because what's coming is
already here I love when a woman's like
nope they're definitely already here
then you see the parademon pop up next
to miles Dyson from terminator he Silas
stone cyborg father so looks like the
parademons have already learned about
cyborg becoming cyborgs they're coming
for that mother box you see Batman
juxtaposed coming to the ocean side to
look for Aquaman in this tiny little
village here he breaks it you actually
get a whole bunch more dialogue from all
the characters they're standing on the
back of the flying fox so it looks like
as they go around recruiting people they
just use that to go around and grab
people core to it a shot of Aquaman grab
that bottle of whiskey from the other
shots that we've seen in all the other
trailers some more cyborg action of him
using his powers to save people some
giant bus save more flash effects so let
me know what you guys think of how the
flash looks and the way he moves in this
obviously it looks way cooler than it
does on a TV show because this is a two
hundred million dollar movie so they
have an ungodly special effects budget
to make everything look super cool we
see that same scene from the comic-con
trail that we've seen before
Batman swinging in just like a comic
book cover to take down parademons he's
also wearing the new tactical suit that
you see in all those promo art that they
released earlier this year this place
that looks like Steppenwolf space or a
ship that they're invading or something
like that something that's built into
the side of a mountain big roll call you
get core 2 - shots of all the new
characters and then some badass Aquaman
didn't I tell you that he was going to
be awesome in this he's so crazy in this
trailer I love this so much
taking down parademons with the Trident
of Poseidon 2 at a time kind of hard to
tell who Wonder Woman's fighting in this
because they're wearing gloves they
don't look like pair demons and in every
other shot of the trailer that is
who they're fighting way more cyborg you
see him activate more of a technologies
he flies up into the atmosphere it looks
like he's flying out of that apocalypse
ship like some crazy technology behind
it here I know a lot of you are like hey
wait a minute isn't it like a Superman
shot usually this is something you would
see Superman flying up through the
clouds to see the Sun or the moon or
something like that but no they've
removed all trace of them from this
trailer this is all about bringing the
other new metahumans together
flash taking down a para demon let me
know what you guys think is a look at
them their armor is very new 52 looking
the designs very Gimli they have armies
of parademons that come from apocalypse
via boomtube but it'll be cool to see if
they actually start turning humans on
Earth into para demons themselves
another solid flash line this is just a
follow up from that earlier scene where
he's recruiting him what's your
superpower again I'm rich so see Batman
does have a sense of humor I feel like
they do a pretty good job of bringing it
across here he doesn't tell jokes but he
does have a really good sense of timing
so sometimes he'll say things that sound
like jokes in the comics so this is
actually really cool people have been
talking about this crazy new version of
the Batmobile it's not the Batmobile
itself it's just like this wall-crawler
device that they use to get up into this
place here so imagine a more tank-like
version of the Batmobile that's capable
of climbing up a mountainside or
climbing up a building so it's almost
like they jumped into some sort of nest
of parademons or something like that
because there's a giant firefight going
on in this location and they use this in
the comic-con trailer it just they
didn't have any of this battle going on
here's a better shot of that tank
cyborg before he became cyborg so I
guess there will be a bit of a flashback
to before he got that mother box fused
with a Wonder Woman banging her gauntlet
on her shield it almost looks like that
shot from Avengers age of Ultron where
Thor bangs his hammer on Captain
America's shield to create a lightning
throw we actually saw a version of this
when they released that behind the
scenes real last year more flash running
Lois Lane it looks like Aquaman here is
trying to stop the ocean from rushing
into the back of the Flying Fox here so
like you banging is tried and down just
stopping this wall of water and oh my
god it's Mira we actually see Mira in
some Atlanteans this is so cool so see
her armor looks just like Aquaman
because it seems like he's already king
of Atlantis but based on what people say
they're not
period yet like he's king of Atlantis
they know each other really well but
they're not like boyfriend and
girlfriend or anything like that
flash talking to his father everybody
that watches the TV show will remember
this they basically did this through
season one of the flash where he was
stuck in prison because he was falsely
accused of killing his mother because
big surprise reverse-flash killed his
mother and then jetted off so that means
that the reverse-flash exists in the DC
EU he just came back during rebirth - so
I know everybody was talking about the
Rogues being the big bags of the flash
solo movie but now it sounds like
they're definitely going to be doing
some reverse flash in the DC EU so you
can just guess about what his costume is
going to look like
the Amazons rolling out in full battle
against the forces of Darkseid this
could be a flashback because there was a
ward that Darkseid lost they were able
to fight him off the three mother boxes
were left on earth or it could be
happening in present day when they all
come back but here's that Batman shot
and the Batmobile fighting the parademon
that we've already seen here's a much
better look at them from the front
Aquaman underwater finding them without
his armor that same flash off from the
teasers that we've seen so far
Wonder Woman dropping down what looks
like a giant shaft into this shot that
we saw the promo image of before they
actually released this a while ago but
this seems like whatever Darkseid ship
is maybe it's built into the ground or
it's an actual ship itself the crazy
thing about this is it's a design
language looks very similar to
Kryptonian but I think it's just meant
to look very alien very organic looking
we finally hear the new Jim Gordon speak
it's good to see you playing well with
others Batman still wearing his old
cloth based costume and then Aquaman
rolls up you dress like a bat I dig it
it's sort of an answer to his so you
talked to fishline from the earlier
trailer that we saw
here you can talk to fish just like a
bat a digging may be temporary he even
gets a little smile out of Batman that's
murk there that's Batman sense of humor
and then you see Aquaman here jump on to
the Batmobile and jump off of it it's so
badass
so even without water around he is still
hardcore but when he's wielding the
Trident he can actually create water
even without it just by himself he is
naturally way stronger Wonder Woman
style taking out some parademon so oh my
god this looks so great so even though
yeah it looks really dark really gritty
there is a lot of fun in here there's a
lot of color so I feel like they listen
to a lot of feedback after Batman V
Superman where it's like yeah you could
have a really hardcore movie but it can
still be a lot of fun and I think that's
what we're all looking for from DC
because Marvel has it staying it does a
lot of fun popcorn movies they're
definitely some serious moment but DC
tried to differentiate itself by doing
something a little more adult I think
that's what this is so they did say they
were open to doing rated R film that is
never going to be a Justice League film
these will always be solid pg-13 just
because they're meant for a broader
audience the rated R version of a DC
movie would be more like Lobo he's kind
of like DC's version of Wolverine you
can just regenerate himself from a drop
of blood so let me know in the comments
like how are you breaking out about this
who are you most excited for like I said
I think Aquaman is going to be the dude
that everybody comes out of this movie
saying he is the best person ever so
after watching this are you just not so
much more hyped for the Aquaman movie
Jason Momoa is going to kill it but I
totally loved Ben Affleck's version of
Batman I can't wait to see what he's
doing in this film the flash looks
pretty cool we didn't see that much from
him though there's very little flash in
this trailer and we'll get the full
Wonder Woman course origin of the DC
Universe in a couple months so we don't
have to wait that long to see her and
they are billing the Wonder Woman movie
as the origin of the DC Universe because
the Amazons are so long lived so when
they say origin you're going to get all
the backstory the context for metahumans
for gods for Darkseid everything in that
movie so now you see why it's important
that we watch Wonder Woman before we
watch Justice League so you get all that
back
taury so you don't have to sideline the
entire Justice League film just
explaining where everything came from
and how we got there
but I do expect one of those Zack Snyder
prequel movies sort of like a silent
film at the beginning of just this week
he does then during all their movies so
obviously I'm expecting something
Darkseid focus so just cannot wait to
see the silent Darkseid film what's
going to happen is is later today I'll
post a video for Darkseid in his minions
they'll talk about Kalibak I'll talk
about the female Furies granny goodness
all the really cool apocalypse
characters that we might see in the DC
Universe so leave all your requests for
Justice League and DC bonus videos in
the comments below I know everybody's
asking me flash questions so I applied
to another flash video in the next
couple days too but I'll say
congratulations to the latest injustice
giveaway winner Michael Coulter please
present message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there was a new round that this
video all announced the winner when I
post that other Justice League video
later today so thank you so much for
watching why he wait for that it was a
brand new guardians killer I just posted
you can click here for that and you can
click here for new flash thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you in the next video